they called them the beatles theirs as a
record of kidnapping torture and
signature executions posted online
they're a group of men from west london
who joined islamic state in syria
homegrown uk terrorists who were at the
forefront of is violence and propaganda
it's not an obligation or a duty of me
to justify or condemn
anything
their nickname stemmed from their
british accents as held in this 2018
interview with sky's stuart ramsey you
have nothing to say to families that
would just lost their husbands who were
actually doing aid work uh
not specifically no i don't have
anything to say to them
these men were behind the kidnap and
murder of more than two dozen hostages
including british citizens
most prominent in this terrorist group
was mohammed emwazi so-called jihadi
john he was killed in an airstrike in
2015.
the remaining two were captured three
years later trying to escape from syria
alexander cote on the left subsequently
pled guilty to his crimes now shafiel
sheikh on the right claimed innocent but
he's now been convicted by an american
jury
relatives of victims heard harrowing
evidence of unrelenting physical and
psychological torture
the public benches of this virginia
courtroom brought together families of
us and uk victims
american journalists james foley and
stephen sotloff were among those killed
so too u.s aid workers kayla mueller and
peter kasich
john cantley a british journalist
remains missing after being seized in
2012.
alan henning an aid worker from salford
in greater manchester was murdered
so was david haynes from perth in
scotland both men were beheaded on
camera
i have never
seen the video and will not see the
video because it is a propaganda
production
david's brother mike was at home in
dundee when he was told of his death i
got my family together i took my mom's
hands
and told her her son couldn't be hurt
anymore
i have never felt such strong
hatred or anger
if somebody could have flicked a switch
and the people who were involved in the
murder of my brother were at my feet
kneeling unarmed
i would have put a pistol to their head
i would have murdered them
and that's the point that it hit me
that his
murder was about the spread of hate
what they wanted was for me to stand up
and point your finger at islam and say
your faith your people and that would
have just caused more division
the authorities had long said there were
four so-called beetles but there was
testimony in this case that there were
only three whatever the number the case
laid bare the brutality of a group of
british men exporting terror
perpetrators of immeasurable cruelty now
facing a measure of justice
james matthews sky news